hi I'm Steve Clemons and I have a
question Western powers are still all in
for Ukraine and F-16 fighter jets are
finally on the table but will the rest
of the world go along with the plan
let's get to the bottom line
[Music]
Ukraine and China were high on the
agenda in the group of seven meeting in
Hiroshima Japan last week Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski was invited
and he got a promise from U.S President
Joe Biden to allow training on
American-made f-16s which is probably a
first step toward getting those fighter
jets to Ukraine up until now the U.S
didn't want to send those weapons to
Ukraine for fear of escalating the war
because they can hit targets deep inside
Russian territory the G7 attacked China
for using so-called economic coercion to
force countries to bend to its will and
China responded by calling the G7 as a
quote exclusive block that's not
representative of most of the world so
where is the Western agenda heading and
can the G7 set the agenda for the whole
world without serious pushback from the
global South does the G7 really even
matter anymore today we're talking with
Ian bremmer president and founder of the
Eurasia Group which studies political
risk around the world and he's the
author of a great book the power of
Christ us Ian thank you so much for
talking to us today about G stuff as I
call it G7 g0 G2 whichever G's we have
but um we just had a G7 meeting in
Hiroshima and I would love to get a
snapshot from you right now on whether
you think this meeting was relevant to
any of us
it's very relevant
um and the G7 has become much more
cohesive much more united in part
because we are living in a g zero world
because there is an absence of Global
Leadership and the presence of threat
and crisis geopolitically the Russian
invasion of Ukraine the Chinese
government becoming much more
economically powerful but not aligned uh
with the United States or its allies in
political or economic system those are
things that are deeply concerning to the
advanced industrial democracies the
principal members of the G7 and you saw
that on display in Hiroshima you saw
that with the invitation of zelenski and
his personal sit-down meetings with
every single one of them in the
extraordinary amount of economic support
and Military Support that's being
provided you also sought with the
greater cohesiveness in concern about
economic coercion as the G7 puts it from
China and greater alignment of U.S and
and other G7 countries in their China
policies their security policies
increasingly their industrial policies
in some areas of the economy so in that
regard the G7 is very important final
point though of course Biden had to cut
short his dinner meeting at the G7 with
the heads of state and then canceled the
rest of his trip why because of
political dysfunction in your town Steve
in Washington DC and the debt limit
crisis that has not yet resolved and
very quickly approaching so is this
feeling to you like a cold war because
it stands out to me that right now China
is the world's second largest economy
India is the fifth the brics countries
Brazil Russia India China South Africa
are planning their own Summit uh soon in
19 other countries want to join up with
them are we seeing the world divide
itself between the G7 Pals of the United
States and everyone else
I think the answer to that is no I mean
look there is unfortunately there's much
worse than a cold war between the G7 and
Russia it's a hot War it's just being
fought largely by proxy and of course
the fact that even f-16s are being
provided going forward and even three
months ago Biden said that could be
tantamount to World War III shows you uh
just how the gloves are off but on China
uh there is a recognition and you saw
this from Janet Yellen Secretary of
Treasury just a few weeks ago giving a
speech for the U.S and you saw this from
Biden over the weekend saying he thought
U.S China relations would improve but
from a low base
um that there is a recognition of
interdependence between the G7 and China
between the U.S and China the term of
art is now de-risking but not decoupling
in other words us and China today have
more trade than at any time with each
other than at any time in history and
while that doesn't sound like a cold war
and if the Americans did want a cold war
none of the American Allies would want
it and of course India you mentions in
the brics but India is also in the quad
and all of those developing countries
many of them have very good security
relations with the us but they have very
strong economic relations with China so
it's a lot more complicated than just
saying Cold War 2.0 but there certainly
is no trust between the United States
and China today and there's increasingly
very little trust between the G7 and
China given that these are the two
largest economies in the world that's
not a comfortable position to be in
you know with with no offense towards
Papua New Guinea which I love I don't
think many Americans uh had any idea
President Biden was scheduled to go
there until he canceled the trip uh to
Papua no Guinea and also to Australia uh
and we've since learned that Papua
nagini has has uh agreed to become a
site of American Naval bases and it
raises this question of whether this
encirclement strategy of laying out
bases military capacity alliances you
know around China which is a Chinese
paranoid fear is actually something they
should be fearful about what are your
thoughts on the military encirclement of
China by the United States and its
allies and Papua New Guinea we need to
recognize that China today is the
dominant trade partner economically for
a large majority of all the countries in
the world and that does not mean that
the Americans are being encircled
economically it just means that China
has a strong and robust economy that the
state is is driving and they are
investing outwardly everywhere and
they'll be the largest economy in the
world probably by 2030 2032 the United
States is the dominant military power in
the world the U.S outspends the next 10
countries in the world in defense the
next 10 countries combined okay so I
mean if that's true if the Americans are
that far ahead of everyone else in
military spending then of course the
majority of military bases out there are
going to be American and what's going to
happen is that countries around the
world will be more aligned with the
United States on Direct National
Security matters and there'll be more
aligned with the Chinese on economic
matters and that will be messy that will
be messy uh but that is not a cold war
and it's also not encirclement because
the fact of American Military dominance
is not in any way preventing the Chinese
from having these extraordinarily robust
economic relations just so happen the
Chinese power is primarily expressed
through their trade and Commercial
relationships not surprising for a state
capitalist political system while the
American influence and power is
partially ideological but frankly that's
been weakened a lot given dysfunction at
home in the United States a lot more of
it is about its military presence and
dominance so this should not be
startling to anyone that pays attention
to the league tables in which which
countries do what
one of the things that's confusing me
right now about Chinese relations with
the West are mixed signals so in one
hand you have the summit about concerned
about Chinese economic coercion in the
world also trying to sort of wrangle if
you will uh in you know basically
try to prevent major investment by the
West in Chinese capacity uh in high-tech
areas in Quantum and Ai and others but
on the other hand uh you've got Joe
Biden comes out and says you know we're
going to see a a thaw in these Chile
relations you're going to see a lot of
our cabinet officials meeting their
counterparts with China and trying to
basically take take the U.S China
relationship into a warmer track than
the cold one it's been on since the Spy
balloon so what's going on
well in the same you would just asked me
in your last question hey should the
Chinese be worried about military
encirclement when the Americans and the
G7 talk about Chinese economic coercion
it is the same concern it's just from a
different lens because the Americans
don't have the ability to do global
economic policy through the state they
can't build
um a belt and Road the way the Chinese
can and the Chinese can't build credible
military bases around the world or a
defense export strategy the way the
Americans can and it turns out that that
reality makes both countries kind of
uncomfortable but despite that the
Americans and the Chinese both see that
they need each other and that that need
is not going to go away so just as
there's a lack of trust and just as
there's concern on the economic and
Military side you also have both
countries wanting to meet and wanting to
talk about those areas where there can
can be a level of Greater cooperation
and that there is a level of Greater
cooperation I mean the trade
relationship is enormous cooperation we
just don't talk about it because the
politics are so dysfunctional climate
clearly both sides would like to see uh
more uh global economic stability the
reaction to the many banking crisis that
the Americans and the Chinese don't want
that to blow up and by the way even the
debt limit I mean Putin I am sure would
love to see the debt limit blow up in
the faces of Biden and U.S political
leaders the Chinese don't want to see
that because the Chinese don't want a
severe U.S recession that because
they're so dependent on the the properly
well-functioning of the of the a global
economy where the U.S is the largest
participant so it shouldn't surprise
anyone that both the Americans and the
Chinese would like a relationship that
is more stable than the politics are
presently driving it you're describing
being a situation in which two
adversaries or Rivals are joined at the
hip and are mutually dependent on each
other's you know survival not just
survival but actually needing to thrive
but it raises another insane question
you know I'm sure you read every word
President Biden says just like I do and
when he was in Hiroshima he talked about
a company Micron a chip maker that has r
d facilities production facilities in
Hiroshima Japan so I wake up and guess
what China has now declared Micron as as
not having met its security tests and it
is now Banning Micron from all of its
infrastructure what are the implications
there is this just a play around Huawei
and what we've been doing to basically
Target Huawei and this is their response
or do you suspect there are now deeper
measures that China is going to take
about uh you know a more you know
adversarial treatment of American Tech
products
well first of all um you're right in
terms of uh adversaries or competitors
uh joined at the hip the way I like to
think of it are parents where the love
has left the relationship uh they're
married still and they have kids and no
matter what they think of each other
they both really love the kids and they
don't want to screw the kids up and so
as a consequence they're going to take
measures and they're going to act in
ways that help ensure that the kids
um aren't aren't mistreated uh that they
can still grow
um and you know that's not easy to do
when the love is left a family
relationship but but there is I think a
level of recognition now the Americans
have levied export controls on a number
of high-end semiconductors that the U.S
considers to be dual use in other words
useful for economics and Military
purposes the Chinese in response have
levied sanctions against Micron
um and Micron does not produce the same
high and advanced chips the tsmc in
Taiwan does the difference being that
China has other sources for those same
chips as the American company Micron and
uh they've and the Americans have
already told the South Koreans who
provide some of those chips to China hey
you should join with us in not providing
those ships because the Chinese are
hitting us and you know the danger is
you don't want to go too far from Dual
use Technologies where there are
legitimate National Security concerns to
broader containment policy on the
economy because then you end up hurting
yourselves you end up taking away from
the interdependence of the U.S China
relationship that not only ensures that
you continue to behave in a civil
fashion towards each other but also
creates more growth more wealth reduces
the cost of goods I mean remember those
you ask me about Micron but you could
have asked me about the Trump Tara
tariffs on Chinese Goods consumer goods
which the Chinese then also levied in
return against American goods and who
got hurt the voters the consumers in the
United States and the citizens in China
who have to pay higher costs for their
goods but you know Biden has no way of
undoing those tariffs even though it
would be good for the economy because he
knows that politically he would get hurt
for it by the polls and and of course by
the Republicans by his opposition so you
do end up cutting off your nose despite
your face in some of these conversations
and of course all of those are not
particularly helpful when you're trying
to wrestle down inflation because they
actually help contribute to inflation
another question recently I interviewed
Robert O'Brien the former National
Security adviser to president Trump and
you know this along with the other fact
that the house select committee on China
recently did a war game exercise looking
at a Chinese invasion of Taiwan how it
would go what the U.S could bring to
bear there and guess what China the high
cost but China succeeded the U.S did not
block that Invasion O'Brien told me that
if there were a successful invasion of
Taiwan that no element of tsmc the
greatest semiconductor manufacturer in
the world would be intact and I'm
interested as a direct quote and I'm
interested in what you know as you look
at it is this you know a basically a
race where we're beginning to look at
Churchill saying about the uh you know
the French Fleet we're not going to
allow that to fall into Nazi hands are
we thinking about extreme scenarios that
this is really about Advanced chips and
not letting China get control of that
industry well so on the one hand it's
fairly obvious that if there's a fight
over Taiwan and the Chinese are about to
take the most strategically important
company in the world for themselves the
Americans aren't going to sit there and
say oh it's fine for you to have it and
that's leaving aside the the flood of
talent that would leave so yeah I think
it's pretty clear that it would be
destroyed I also think it's highly
irresponsible for the former National
Security advisor of the U.S to be
opining on that topic in the same way
that a sitting National Security advisor
should not be in my view I I think you
should sort of if you're in a position
to make that decision you know you
should kind of keep that quiet because
it only makes the relationship worse
difference between an analyst and a
policy maker
um but but in the war games I've been
involved in between the U.S China and
Taiwan
um the way it usually plays out is not
military confrontation because it's
obvious to both sides that it would
cause such damage economically and
rather the Chinese leveraging the power
they have as I've already mentioned to
you the economic power and of course
Taiwan overwhelmingly is dependent on
Mainland China economically just as
they're dependent on the U.S and
Australia and others for their security
and so what that means is if you're
China and you want to change the status
quo you put export controls on Taiwanese
companies until they behave in ways that
are more patriotic and loyal to the
mainland you you know you take actions
against Taiwanese CEOs
um you say you're going to cut them off
um from Mainland Chinese trade and that
way you get vastly more influence over
the behavior of the Taiwanese political
system and of their economy without
suddenly threatening war that you're
probably going to have massive negative
impact from right Ian do you put much
stock in the West's response to the
China belt and Road initiative and what
they call the partnership for Global
infrastructure does that have any chance
of meaning anything
nope uh it's uh the United States is a
capitalist pre-market economy it does
not drive significant private sector
investment and it doesn't do much public
sector investment so it is useful at the
margins there will be some you know high
standard Investments that help to move
the needle in transition energy
economies for example and some areas of
high-tech but on balance if the United
States is going to have more influence
around the so-called Global South it
will not be by competing in the areas
where the Chinese are dominant
structurally dominant it'll be in other
areas I was recently in Warsaw Poland
and also Tallinn Estonia and National
Security forums and I have to say that
among European friends the feeling was
pervasive one of thanks to the United
States for all it had done in Ukraine
but also frustration with what they saw
as the Biden Administration dithering on
key a weapons decisions and whatnot and
marshalling you know the support that
zielinski needs they feel uh to push
Russia out of the picture and they they
fear that America is designing what may
become or at least acquiescing to a
frozen conflict something like North and
South Korea this was a pervasive View
and they said in that world Putin wins
and the West loses do you have thoughts
on that well first of all you were you
said you were in Poland and um in in
Latvia Estonia Estonia assuming Estonia
Tallinn yes uh Estonia
um and I I would point out that those
are two of the European countries that
are most strongly aligned with defending
Ukraine and more hawkishly disposed
towards Russia than any of the other
Europeans it's the Baltic states Poland
and the nordics not so you weren't in
France you weren't in Germany you surely
weren't in Italy or Spain and I'm saying
that because I don't want people to
think that that perspective you just
gave is a broad European perspective it
is not the European perspective is
fairly divided on Military Support for
Ukraine the Americans are of course
doing more than any other country by a
long margin that's not surprising given
America's power but also the Americans
are the ones that have been pushing and
they are more closely aligned with the
countries you just mentioned the ones I
just mentioned that's particularly true
now uh because of Biden's willingness to
support these Storm Shadow missiles
coming from the UK which is a precursor
to the Americans providing attacks to
Ukraine also the willingness to train
Ukrainian pilots on the f-16s that's a
precursor to providing f-16s and
allowing other countries to in other
words the gloves from the United States
on providing Military Support to Ukraine
are off and you'll see that that support
you will see military and security
guarantees and of course you will also
see economic support for reconstruction
and all of those things are meant as
precursors for what will be at some
point some form of negotiations between
the Russians and the ukrainians and the
Americans want the ukrainians to be in a
much stronger position
militarily economically and
diplomatically before they start
engaging in negotiations that's why the
Americans have waited for the
counter-offensive and that's why the
Americans are stepping up the military
support they're providing for Ukraine so
I actually think the concerns that you
have raised are diminishing and and as
of the G7 in Hiroshima and are likely to
to diminish over the course of what we
hope will be a relatively successful
Ukrainian counter-offensive final
question Ian and thank you so much for
your candor and all of this but I agree
with you that the G7 as as I've seen it
you haven't seen it this aligned in a
long time at the same time it's concerns
about China it's very big concerns about
Russia Russia is now the most sanctioned
country in the world I don't even know
what more you can sanction they found
200 more ways to sanction Russia what
what's remarkable to me is how easy it
is in this world today to end run
anything that G7 does the the Russian
economy is resilient in the face of all
this China has its own forms of
resilience and it just brings me back to
this question of how much traction does
the G7 really have in and I say this in
the world so respectful of you looking
at the G zero realities out there do
they fundamentally matter anymore when
you can matter they matter less the G7
used to be it the G7 used to run the
world and then the Russians were brought
in after Soviet collapsed the G7 plus
one and that didn't work very well then
you created the G20 the G20 the 20
largest economies but they weren't the
line so the G22 could couldn't do very
much they didn't have the same ability
to move the ball so yes the G7 still
matters and if you sanction the Russians
so heavily of course that means the gas
can't go anywhere it gets flared because
if the Europeans don't buy it you can't
build infrastructure anywhere else but
you can't do that on food because
they're important for the global South
you can't do that in oil because others
will buy it and so it is more limited
and so if the G7 talks people listen but
let's be clear that you know in a
relatively short order the bricks are
going to represent a larger percentage
of the global economy than the G7 does
that's even if you don't expand the
bricks and you probably are going to
expand the bricks so what does that mean
it's more complicated and there's a lack
of Global Leadership and that's why I
wrote about the G zero ten years ago I
always learn from Ian bremmer who is
president and founder of the Eurasia
group and author of The Power of Crisis
thank you so much for being with us
today good to be with you so what's the
bottom line it was almost 80 years ago
when the global pecking order was
established with the United States and
its friends on top now that order is
coming undone old Arrangements like the
Group of Seven which started after the
Arab Oil Embargo of 1973 sort of looked
like a relic from a museum it's true
that those countries represent half of
the world's wealth today but they've got
only 10 percent of the world's people
today China is the world's second
largest economy and India is fifth but
they're not members these days China can
veto progress on just about anything and
other countries like Brazil India and
Russia well they can Flex their muscles
as well it used to be that whatever the
Western Powers wanted became the rules
of the world those days are really gone
maybe we're heading to a g zero world
where no country's in charge or maybe a
G2 world where China and the US set all
the global deals but the reality is the
Sun is setting on the G7 world and
that's the bottom line
foreign
[Music]